what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in you what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet I
started to mention me serious with the
goal to try to learn from people who've
done a lot more than us try to hang out
with people who had more success in us
and hopefully some of their beliefs some
of their mindset some of their way of
working reaching us to help us become
the best version of ourselves so today
we're going to learn from Will Smith and
his work ethic mentor me will rule
number three is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the best also as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below I put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired by it as
well and if you leave it within the
first couple hours of this video going
live you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes
[Music]
you
I think that you are so incredible in
all areas and you are so talented in so
many ways obviously but and you seem to
have always been this I mean I obviously
we grow and we get better and better but
what what was the driving force have you
always been on some kind of quest to be
better you know there was um excuse me
there was a moment when I was about nine
years old and I was at the resurrection
Baptist Church where the church I went
to growing up and my grandmother was
always in charge of all of the recitals
and the Easter recitations and all of
that stuff so I was playing the piano
and I remember my grandmother was
standing back offstage and she put me
last in the show and everything and I
had learned of Farrelly's and I was
playing for a lease and I'm going and
going and going and I'd never learned
how to end it right so I was just
playing playing to play and my
grandmother was there than backstage and
I was looking at playing and that look
of pride and happiness on my
grandmother's face is that that's my
life force everything I do I just need
that look you know and my wife's eyes
and my daughters are it's just you know
realizing I've realized very very young
that there's no easy way around it no
matter how talented you are your talent
is going to fail you if you're not
skilled you know if you don't study if
you don't work really hard and dedicate
yourself to being better every single
day you'll never be able to communicate
with with people with your artistry the
way that you want so it's a that moment
I just remember so distinctly and how
good it felt and and I just need it yes
I believe and
are very young from parents from my
parents absolutely that you you don't
try to build a wall you don't set out to
build a wall you don't say I'm going to
bake this still the biggest fattest
greatest wall that's ever been built you
know start there
you say I'm going to lay this brick as
perfectly as a brick can be laid there
will not be one brick on the face of the
earth that's going to be laid better
than this brick that I'm going to lay in
this next ten minutes and you do that
every single day and so you you have a
wall and I think psychologically the
advantage that that gives me over over a
lot of people that I have been in
competition with in different situations
is it's difficult to take the first step
when you look how big the task is the
task is never huge to me
it's always you need one Brittany two
there there's a concept that I don't
want to be an icon I want to be an idea
you know I want to represent an idea i
want to represent possibilities I want
to represent magic right that you're in
a universe in two plus two equals four
two plus only equals four if you accept
it two plus two equals four two plus two
is going to be what I want it to be you
know and there's that there's a like
there's that there's a redemptive power
that making a choice has you know rather
than feeling like you're at a fete to
all the things that are happening make a
choice like you just decide what is
going to be who you're going to be how
you're going to do it just decide and
then from that point the universe is
going to get out your way this lets
water it once move it wants to move and
go around stuff you know so for me I
want to represent possibilities I want
to represent the idea that you really
can
make what you want one of my favorite
books is the The Alchemist Paulo Coelho
and that's just I just believe that I
believe that I can create whatever I
want to create if I can put put my head
on it right study it learn the patterns
and you know I just I it's hard to put
into words real better physical esoteric
nonsense but I feel very strongly that
we are who we choose to be the only
thing that I see that is distinctly
different about me is I'm not afraid to
die on a treadmill right I will run it
would not be outworked I will not be
outworked right here you yeah you know
you might have more talent than me you
might be smarter than me you might be
sexier than me you might be all of those
things you got it on me in nine
categories but if we get on the
treadmill together right there's two
things you're getting off first I'm
going to die it's really that simple
right so let's go back to the question
about what if people block me out
there's going to be two options yeah I'm
going to get back in or I'm going to be
dead Yeah right it's like you're not
going to outwork me it's a very is such
a simple basic concept is the the guy
who is willing to hustle the most is
going to be the guy that just gets that
loose ball you know he got though he got
the oh okay he got to oh god he's
hustling grabbed out my dad was going to
be out of bounds but he saved it back in
it's like the commodity that I see the
majority of people who aren't getting
the places they want or aren't achieving
the things that they want in this
business is strictly based on hustle
it's strictly based on being out work is
strictly based on missing crucial
opportunities I
all the time if you stay ready you ain't
got to get ready I realized that when
you have the level of success that I
want to have it's difficult to spread it
out and do multiple things you know it's
in order to to be world-class and I've
made a decision I want to be world-class
and it just it takes such a desperate
obsessive focus to to excel on a certain
honor on the level that I want to make
movies you know I was a Star Wars when I
was young i sat in the movie theater and
watched Star Wars and I just couldn't
believe that that movie made me feel
like that just floored and just stunned
by the creativity and just I'm realizing
that in order to move people in that way
in order to touch people in that way
you've really got to focus with all of
your fiber and all your heart and all
your creativity a lot of people talk
about talent they say look you are
multi-talented and that's why you're a
superstar you differentiate though
between talent and hard work
absolutely numerous I've never really
dude myself as particularly talented I
view myself as you know slightly above
average and talent where I excel is
ridiculous sickening work ethic you know
while the other guys sleeping I'm
working while the other guys eating I'm
working while the other guys making love
well I mean I'm making love to but we're
really hard at it working very hard so
when the phone rings that you can alarm
goes off there's Denzel Washington right
now is hooking up you got a guy down
right now right you don't for being
there it's like the the separation of
talent and skill is one of the the the
greatest misunderstood concepts for
people who are trying to excel who have
dreams that want to do things talent you
have naturally skill is only developed
by hours and hours and hours of beating
on your craft and you know for me it's I
feel like I have a relationship with the
audience they agree that they're going
to go in droves and I agree that every
time they go is going to be better than
the last time so I think that's part of
the the relationship and I'm going to
hold up my part as long as they keep
although bears the concept of improving
lives runs through the center of
everything I do and then I reel
is that the way to improve lives is to
continually improve yourself right so
with that every every morning when I
when I get out of the bed you know I I
haven't fixed everything in the world
yet so there's always something to do
and in this film I read an interesting
quote for the Siddhartha Gautama the
Buddha he said that good people have to
get out of the bed every day and try to
empty the ocean with a ladle right and I
thought that was you know I knew that
was profound and I paused for a second
and I said all right what the hell is a
ladle right right so there you know I
just touched it on my iPad is ladle oh
it's like a big spoon a big phone okay I
look like a spoon a soup spoon other why
you're suitable so try to empty the
ocean with a soup spoon you know as the
mentality of how you you wake up every
day to try to do good in the world so
for me I'm I'm really driven by
continually trying to elevate my elevate
my mind and elevate my spirit and care
for my body and to be able to love as
many people as effectively as as
possible with this mystery of life that
I've been given thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love
to know what did you learn from this
video what clip spoke the most to you
and how are you going to apply it
immediately somehow in your life or in
your business please leave it down the
comments below also if you're leaving a
comment within the first few hours of
this video going live you have a chance
to win one of two daily prizes I also
want to give a quick shout out to surge
wisdom thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and
doing multiple reviews on your youtube
channel going chapter by chapter by
chapter I really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book
[Music]
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon